the dangerous thing is to have a Patrick
set of regulations can make it really
hard for a company to operate hi I'm
Alexis Garcia with reason TV here at the
Atlantic City lab in Los Angeles and
right now i'm joined by John Zimmer he's
the co-founder of lift now John you know
we're at this conference and talk a
little bit about what services like lift
do to help a city grow yeah so one of
the biggest reasons that young people
are moving into cities or or not is
accessibility to to everything in that
city and so transportation is incredibly
powerful to help empower small
businesses to get people to those small
businesses to help people live in more
affordable places so that they can then
get into the city where they work so
transportation is incredibly important
to City growing their jobs and and
people moving to that city I talked a
little bit about being here because
you're essentially around people that
would like to regulate you yeah and you
know talk a little bit about what cities
can do to really encourage the growth of
businesses like yours yeah I mean we
have had mayor's across the country
whether it's you know Kevin Johnson in
Sacramento or Bill Peduto in Pittsburgh
actually asked for a lift to come to
their city that's really helpful right
because sometimes we hear the opposite
which is when we when we go to that city
were met with resistance I think what
we'd like to engage in dialogue and talk
about the rules that were created mostly
decades ago let's have an open
conversation about why and typically you
know it's around safety and safety
something we're very comfortable talking
about because we have extensive driving
record checks background checks
insurance that often goes beyond what
those regulations require but we do it
in a different way and so typically what
we really just need is to have an open
dialogue around adapting rules such that
it works for this new model so that
everyone eventually could be a lyft
driver as long as they pass the
screening which would empower this new
form of ride-sharing where you can get
wherever you need to go really quickly
with a neighbor and are you finding that
you're getting that dialogue because I
know just recently here
los angeles and san francisco bay again
serves you and you know a couple other
popular services like uber again with
the safety with the background checks do
you think there is that dialogue going
on because it seems like you guys are
shown that you are doing this why do you
I mean we've been working on we go
working for with the PUC the Public
Utilities Commission which is you know
California wide for for a couple years
now but what we realized that there's
many agencies with you know at a state
and local level and there are many
interests and existing industries and so
often when we work really hard to solve
a problem with you know the state agency
the Public Utilities Commission then the
legislature comes out with something
that's being supported by trial lawyers
or insurance companies or city attorneys
have separate issues that they're
concerned about from their constituents
or existing industries so it's really
challenging there's like there's like a
lot of admin work yeah there's like and
the scary thing where the dangerous
thing is to have a patchwork set of
regulations can make it really hard for
a company to operate because we have to
have different you know standards in
every place and when you think about
this ultimate solution which is people
traveling from city to city from state
to state sharing rides it's way it's
much better to have one set of strong
safe rules so what will be the one thing
that lawmakers could do or maybe not do
that would help companies like yours
succeed I think what would be really
interesting in cities across the country
is to have an agency that looks at
innovation and a lot of cities are
starting to do this San Francisco does
this where we're based and but within I
haven't seen yet a model where within
that innovation group they start looking
at regulations and they think forward
five years ten years to think through
how can we maintain the things that are
important to us safety as the example
but still allow for this type of
innovation and so having people really
thinking forward within the agency I
think could be really
well John thank you so much for joining
that yeah thanks for having me for
reason TV i'm alexis garcia